Jad, Robert, Radiolab. Are
these all 24 amendments?
Do you have songs? Oh my friend. Did
you say 24 amendments are the 26?
I don't know how many there were
there. 27, 27 of you. Of all people.
I thought we'd know that. I know where
they re they add one every so often. So,
okay, let me explain this. Let me
explain this project for you. Okay. Okay.
So a more perfect now is
entering its third season, right?
Yay.
The first two seasons,
what were they? They were,
they were extended investigative, uh,
highly reported and researched and
elaborated stories about the supreme court
cases in front of the screen. Yeah.
But the idea was of more perfect cause
always broader than just the court.
I mean,
the idea is to look at the argument that
just so happens to happen at the court
and in the process of America sort of
trying to try to claw its way out of the
muck to get to higher ideals.
Now those ideals of course,
are outlined in the constitution,
which has been amended 27 times in
ways that are crucially important.
Especially right now. And uh,
most Americans can't name
more than one or two of them.
I was one of those people
before more perfect. And so, uh,
when I was on my break, I
had this idea, crazy idea,
which was could we make an album?
Could we make a school house rock for
the 21st century that reanimated these
amendments. Oh, a lot
of times aspiration. Oh,
well it's like you got to go big, right?
That's a very didactic thing like that.
In those songs you actually are told
exactly how to feel about the concert.
I'm just a bill. Yes.
I'm only a bill and I'm
sitting here on Capitol Hill.
Yes.
But the idea was could we take the spirit
of it but not like didactic in the way
the old stuff was.
But like taking these things that we had
been covering for two seasons with the
amendments of the constitution,
the bill of rights one through 10,
the other ones from 11 to
27, uh, taking them and, and,
and because they're so stodgy
and musty, like the language,
some of them are really
opaque. Yeah. I mean,
and so the idea was could we take
these stuffy, stodgy, sometimes opaque,
deeply important, uh,
words and bring them to life.
So we reached out to a ton of
different musicians and ask them like,
would you interpret these amendments? Uh,
you can talk explicitly about
the amendments if you want,
or you can turn it into
something very personal to you.
What could they do it
though? Let me, I don't know.
Let me just play you a couple of, let
me see me. Let me wish I play one.
Should I choose one? Choose one? Yeah.
Okay. I'm going to choose swimming.
Suffrage. Which one is that?
That's the 1919 yeah. Oh,
you can show us a good one. You
chose a good one, my friend.
Am I going to get musically
first of all? Okay.
You're going to get drum
roll please. Dolly Parton,
Dolly Parton, Dolly, Dolly Parton
Doll E. Pardon? Or a Dolly puck. The dog
and the tourney dollar
doll hyphen eve. No, no,
I was just maybe your middle name. Like
Robert E. Lee. His first cousin please.
No. Sally Martin. Really? Yes.
I'll play a little bit of her song.
August 18th,
1920 women suffrage and then ratify.
Women have been fighting for the legal
right to vote since the 1840s in 1890 the
national American women's
suffrage association in a
w s a was established with
Susan B. Anthony is leading force.
Women have been fighting for their
rights since the very beginning of time.
[inaudible] first they said
we couldn't have danced.
Them said we couldn't
drink. Some man allowed it.
They said we couldn't think.
They said we shouldn't speak to.
We were spoken to.
There's just so much we were
allowed to do, but the first month,
I'm just reading the truth.
That's when you got smart nuts,
truth, but
we have to fight for women's
rights. They certainly
[inaudible] we can size because of
times marched up and down the streets,
the women's rights walk nesters on
our feet. We got tired of seeing.
Then we can tell how [inaudible] Thrones,
Ali Brown, when women
finally got the right tempo.
So good. There's so many great
turns of phrases in that song.
Wow. Do you want to hear
another one? I mean,
I'm really curious about like a, an
amendment like a technical and member,
like the 25th, like what
could you possibly, oh,
let me play the 25th you on
here though. One Oh 25th is the,
is the [inaudible] oh, that's very
interesting. This is session one.
The 25th Amendment is the amendment that
that establishes an order of succession
if the president can't do his
job. So Devendra Banhart is a, um,
is a sort of a freak folk musician.
He does like sort of psychedelic
folk. Uh, good Tillich folk. It's a,
it's a whole genre. Hello,
my name is Devendra Banhart and I
chose the 25th amendment truths about
succession.
He's an amazing songwriter and he wrote
a really funny song that takes you
through the line of succession.
[inaudible] 1600 Washington
DC that we're in on no pony
[inaudible] even though I'm
at the bottom of the beds.
[inaudible] succession,
that's been [inaudible] since
the 17 hundreds till today.
[inaudible].
It all began when the president at a
sudden total awakening that completely
rearrange this state of hog [inaudible].
And even worse than a newly grown moral
compass in a developing code of ethics,
they got into [inaudible] [inaudible].
And so at the White House they win
and next came the vice president.
Too much drywall, I have to
sing, Lincoln's Co's float. Oh,
so very distant proving the pole
[inaudible] and so the speaker
of the House of Representatives,
puppets and lead the, due to the
little jobs roles and responsibilities,
they rarely spoke. And so
ironically, when it came time to tug,
they clammed up. And so the president
[inaudible] sure.
So what he's doing is he's knocking off
every person who becomes president and
then you find that you meet the
next one in the line. And I think,
I think the sort of the,
the whole conceit is that everybody
dies and it also ends up with him being
president. Wow. So,
so some musicians really went to law
books and just look very kid some case.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's try one more where we
just get somebody took the
idea of the amendment and
went with a feeling rather than with
the list. Yeah. First Amendment is good.
The First Amendment,
number one, the big one.
[inaudible] let me play that
one after the break. Hi,
this is Ravi calling
from Brooklyn. New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, it's Chad. I boom.
Rod this season and more perfect from
w NYC studios might be the most perfect
yet
19th amendment women have been fighting
for the legal right to vote since the
1840s. This season we are making
an album featuring, for example,
Dali part an album of songs and stories
inspired by the amendments to the u s
constitution.
Listen to more perfect
wherever you get your podcasts.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad. I have him. Rod, he
was a rapper. Krulwich uh,
offering up a preview of an experiment
that we're doing for the new season of
more perfect, uh, where we
are releasing an album. Uh,
it's called 27 the most perfect album.
You can find it on iTunes and Spotify.
You can also find all the
songs@themostperfectalbum.org. Now,
on the podcast, uh, we're not
just putting out music, we're,
we're telling stories. We're telling
these sort of funny, quirky, poetic,
sometimes sad, sometimes hilarious, uh,
sort of explainer stories about
each of the 27 amendments.
I think of them as sort of like
audio liner notes for the songs. Uh,
let me play you, uh, the,
the story that we tell in conjunction
with the first amendment in the podcast.
Sorry, Karrie, producer it more
perfect. Created this little story.
I'm gonna drop into the middle of it
where she's talking with a guy named Burt
Neuborne who is a law
professor and he to him,
the first amendment is like a poem.
So let's drop into that one. You'll
hear a reporter Sar Cari, uh,
actor Jeffrey Wright reading
the amendments and professor
Burt Neuborne talking
about First Amendment, freedom
of religion, speech, Press,
assembly and petition.
It consists of six ideas.
Congress shall make no law respecting
an establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof or
abridging the freedom of speech or the
press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition the
government for a redress of grievances.
Six it's only 45 words long.
It could have been written
on the back of an envelope
these days.
The first amendment is wrapped up in all
kinds of thorny stuff like kneeling at
football games and hate
speech and money in politics.
But if you just step back from all of
that and you read the text of the first
amendment and you really try to think
about what the words are trying to say,
you find that the logic behind it is
[inaudible]
kind of beautiful.
And the order of the words in the
first amendment is the lifecycle of a
democratic idea.
Here's what he means.
So those first two clauses,
Congress shall make no law respecting
an establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof.
Create a free space inside your mind
to think and believe as you wish.
That's the founder saying that space
inside your head where you think your
thoughts that sacred. The
government can't touch that
without that free space. That
can be no shelf government.
So that's the first idea,
the freedom of your thoughts.
[inaudible]
once you've believed
and thought something,
then bet it's natural for
you to want to say it.
Which brings us to the next clause
or abridging the freedom of speech.
The speech clause says,
if you've got an idea formed
in the freedom of your mind,
by all means go ahead and share it. So
you have the freedom to think of thought,
the freedom to speak that
thought, but that's not a new,
if you really want to make a real
new type of dance in a society,
so you need some way to be able to speak
to one of the mass of people to speak
their really loud voice, which brings
you to the fourth clause for the press,
which is speech amplify.
Then once you've gotten your message
out to a large number of people where
people would listen to these
ideas and move by them,
it's natural for those people to
want to do something about it,
to move together, to organize for
the right of the people piece of it.
[inaudible]
so you can think of thigh,
you can speak that thought.
You can create a movement,
but that's not enough.
Finally, the petition clause,
which is the sixth idea.
The petition clause says once you've
assembled, once you've organized,
just wait up man. The protection
of our curves, the amendment rights
we have, sir, we are sir.
They do have a right to take your argument
to the government and to petition the
government for a redress of grievances.
We can speak for this country
and we demand reform now
forced the government into confronting
it and either accepting or rejecting and
then that government, if it says no is
subject to being voted out of office
[inaudible]
so this is Madison giving us
the blueprint for tomorrow.
[inaudible]
when democracy begins
the way I'm hearing it is like like co
centric circles like starting in inside
the mind of one person and then
like reverberating out. No,
exactly.
The First Amendment is a a series of
concentric circles beginning within your
mind and then moving to your closer
acquaintances then to the society at large
and then finally to the entire
polity to the entire people.
I bet that by the way is the only time
in human history that those six ideas
have ever been United in
a single taxed. Only time.
I went back and looked at every single
rights bearing document in our tradition
all the way from the magna Carta
through the English bills of rights,
through the colonial charters,
through the state constitution,
through the French declaration
of the rights of man.
It's never been done before to put the
six building blocks of democracy together
in a single coherent text.
[inaudible] the first amendment
is the ideal city on the hill.
It is the ideal community that the
founders were trying to establish and
remember, establish for the
first time in human history.
[inaudible] wow. [inaudible] I've
never thought of it that way.
It's a little bit like some kind of a
very thoughtful relay race where each,
as the baton is passed, it's,
it's the next logical step to turning
what is inside you into powerful
statements outside of you.
Yeah, so that's a the first
amendment line. Right.
Well, actually, the other
thing about that, about,
now that you've got me thinking about
the way that kite described the first
amendment as this progression
of ideas, I mean it's, it's,
it just comes almost like just in about
a couple of centuries after people like
Shakespeare and Servon Dyson begin
creating interiority like this.
Like they want to ne did,
you really wasn't any place to go to hear
someone talking to herself or himself.
Yeah. And not even a
couple of centuries path.
And then you get a government that,
that takes that idea that people have an
interior and that interior is distinct
and needs protection from the
government and then comes this,
this six point flow. Wow. I
never really thought of that.
Yeah, it's a cool idea.
Um, but interestingly,
the song that that's paired
with at, um, on the album,
I mean actually if we've got a couple
of different submissions for the first
amendment, but one of them came from, uh,
a guy named Joey styles.
He's a native Canadian, uh,
first nation Matisse,
um, hip hop artist. And,
uh, he made a song which sort of argues
with the spirit of Bert newborns take,
um,
he sort of looked at sort
of all the people that have
been left out of that city
on the hill.
How my track goes. As part two,
I was dealing with the freedom of religion
from 1870 up until 1934 was legal for
native Americans to
practice our ceremonies.
I had in mind specifically the ghost
dance as an 1890 at wounded knee,
150 to 300. Mostly women and children
were massacre for ghost dancing.
And to me that shows they were
scared. They were scared of us,
have in our culture and ceremonies
because they empower us.
I truly hope the warrior spirit shines
on this track on a natural side of being
wild or free sets the tone. Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
where you up to solve for the people? Oh,
now we'll never fear any. This is really,
I mean the lyrics and the
musical traces are all not there.
There you really challenge your sense
of the amendment a little bit so that
these songs, the way they're written
and the words that have been chosen,
and then when did they
even strike our hall?
Either arguments of tempo or arguments
of spirit or arguments of history.
Yeah. I would say 80% of
the songs on the record, um,
are arguments with the amendments rather
than just celebrations or explanations
of them. Uh, it's, it's, yeah. Well
this is very interesting. It's cool,
right? Yeah. So a very different
way to do it. Yeah. Um, so that was,
this was just a preview it for
years to, to hear more, uh,
go to wherever you get podcasts,
search for more. Perfect. Um, sign up
radiolab.org/more. Perfect.
We'll take you there. Um,
if you want to hear the record, it's a
great record. I'm so proud of it. Uh,
go to iTunes, Spotify,
wherever, searched for 27,
the most perfect album,
and you can hear all the songs in
their entirety@themostperfectalbum.org.
Okay. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.